below is a drawing of vectors u V and W
sort the cards according to the quantity
they represent if a card doesn't
represent any of the quantities it
should be left unsorted so let's see
what they have over here so this they've
drawn vector V here in blue vector W
here in magenta and then a vector u here
in purple and so let's see what the
choice is let's see what the choices are
the rectangular coordinates three comma
four so if we go three along the x axis
in the positive direction and then we go
up four one two three four we get to the
head of vector V and its tail that it
started at the origin so this could this
could write over here represent a vector
V if we say hey look the tail of our
vector is going to be at the origin then
this coordinate right over here
represents the head of a vector this
could be a representation for vector V
another way to think about it is vector
V from its tail goes three in the
horizontal direction and four in the
vertical direction so that's another way
to think about it so I would say that's
definitely a representation of vector V
now see the number five well the number
five won't represent a vector this is
just this is just a number this could be
a magnitude but to be a vector we need a
magnitude and a direction but right over
here we have the magnitude of vector V
so let's think about whether v could be
the magnitude of vector V if v is the
magnitude it would be the length of this
vector and we could think about that
from the Pythagorean theorem
this side right over here has length
three that side over there has length
four you might recognize this as a 3 4 5
triangle or another way to think about
it we use the Pythagorean theorem 3
squared is 9 plus 4 squared plus 16 is
25 which is going to be this magnitude
squared so the magnitude of vector V is
5 so we could throw that right over here
the magnitude of vector V is 5 or we
could say the length of the length of
this I guess how we've depicted the
vector now let's look at vector u well
vector U is just a shifted
representation of vector
notice if we start at his tail you move
three to the right and four up three to
the right and four up so vector U is
really the same thing as a vector V we
don't care about where they start we
just care about how much do they from
the tail to the head how much do you
move in the horizontal direction and how
much do you move in the vertical
direction and for both of them you move
positive 3 in the horizontal and
positive 4 in the vertical so vector u
really is the same thing as vector V for
thinking in vector terms now a vector
vector vector W this if we start at the
tail to go to the head we have to we
have to go negative three in the X
direction and negative four in the Y
direction so vector W is the negative of
vector V or the negative effect are you
but it's not equal to either one of them
so we're all done we have set up these
are the quantities that are in the
appropriate appropriate buckets